former president trump has sued  basically all of  social media for deplatforming him he  has sued twitter  facebook and youtube claiming that they  somehow violated the first amendment by  kicking him off of their platforms this  is going to fail spectacularly number  one  he filed as a class action this is not a  class action  second of all you the viewer seemed to  know more about section 230 of the  communications decency act than former  president trump  and his lawyers it doesn't do the things  that he says  it does it's the first amendment that  allows them to kick him off  of their platform it's not section 230  and this whole thing  may be sanctionable former president  trump filed suit in florida which has an  anti-slap law it's not a particularly  strong one but it does exist  so this whole lawsuit may be kicked out  on an anti-slap so  we'll see if we see them in court